Okay, let us set aside predicate calculus, and return back to population logic.
Recall that we had found ways of writing sentences in population chronologic.
We had found rules of inferences, we could prove theorems.
We could find the truth value of new sentences.
However, we found that those methods were computationally, not very efficient.
So AI has developed more efficient methods.
One of those methods is called Resolution Theorem Proving.
Let us take an example to illustrate how resolution theorem proving works.
So, imagine there is a robot, and this robot.
Is working on an assembly line,
it's a factory robot, and on the assembly line are coming weird kind of widgets.
The robot's task is to pick up each widget, as it comes on the assembly line and
put it in a truck.
However, there are some humans in this factory.
Who play a joke on the robot once in a while,
they glued the widget to the assembly line belt, so that,
when the robot tries to move it, it can not move it.
But the robot is a smart robot,
this is a logical agent, so when it can not move it.
It uses its logical reasoning, to figure out that the boxes aren't liftable.
And the moment it knows that the boxes aren't liftable,
it let's go of the box and moves onto the next one.
Everyone got the story?
All right.
So let us suppose that the robot begins with some knowledge in
its knowledge base.
And this knowledge in its knowledge base,
that it begins with says that if cannot move, then it implies that not liftable.
Now, it tries to move the box, the next box in the widget.
It's biceps tells it, it can not move.
It needs to prove that it's not liftable.
And of course this is a preview example and I'm sure you'll understand it.
You can put essentially a class of the modest components to
prove that it's not liftable.
If p then q, p therefore you can infer q.
But, we'll use this example to show.
How does resolution theorem proving works?
So, the first step in resolution theorem proving is,
to convert every sentence into a conjunctive normal form.
A conjunctive normal form of a sentence, can have one of three conditions.
It can have a literal.
That can be either a positive atom, or a negative atom.
It can have this disjunctional literals like here can-move, or
not liftable, or it can have a conjunction of disjunctional request.
In this example the third condition doesn't occur.
So, the first thing we must do is to take the first sentence.
The negation of not move implies not liftable.
And remove the implication,
because an implication cannot occur in conjunctive normal form.
So the first thing we need to do is,
to rewrite the sentence, the first sentence, to remove the implication.
Because the implication cannot occur in a conjunctive normal form.
So now we use the.
Implication elimination rewrite rule.
To rewrite this in the form of can-move, or not liftable.
Remember that was alpha implies beta becomes, not alpha or beta.
So the not of negation of can-move becomes can-move or not liftable.
So, we have done it for the first sentence.
This is now in a conjuncted normal form.
We can do the same thing for the second sentence, but
wait, the second sentence already is in a conjunctive form.
We don't have to do anything.
Now, the robot wants to prove that their box is not liftable.
Resolution to improving, is like proof by refutation.
To do proof by refutation we will take the negation of what we want to prove.
We wanted to prove not liftable would take its negation,
which makes it liftable.
Okay, so now we got three sentences.
This one's the first sentence that the robot was bootstrap with,
you've just converted to a conductor normal form.
This was the sentence that came from a it saw that the box cannot move.
And this is the sentence throughout the negation of the sentence,
the refutation of the sentence that it wants to prove.
So we have three sentences now.
The first sentence came from the bootstrapping, of the robot's knowledge base.
This is the axiom that the robot assumes to be true.
The second sentence came from its percepts.
The robot tried to move the box, it could not move it.
The third sentence is coming from taking the negation of
what the robot wants to prove.
It wants to prove it's not liftable.
So, it's going to take this negation of it and then, sure that it's going to
lead to a null condition that we'll view as a contradiction.
The resolution for
improving lawless begin with a liftable in the sentence that we want to prove.
So here that sentence is liftable, and we'll look for a sentence that contains
a negation of liftable in this sentence that we want to prove.
So the sentence here was liftable, sentence S1 contains liftable which is
a negation of that so we pick S1 and not S2.
Note, how efficient it was to decide what sentence on
the knowledge based to go to.
In sentence container negation of the liftable.
So, liftable and not liftable can not both be true.
We know that, and therefore we can eliminate them.
This is called resolution.
We resolve unliftable and we remove them from the sentences.
Now, we were sentence as S1, that leaves us can move.
So, now we pick a sentence, that has the negation of literal can-move.
Sentence S2 has a negation of that, and we can resolve one can move,
they can not both be true.
When we resolve on both of them, those get eliminated as well.
And now we see we've reached another condition.
This null condition represents a contradiction, and
now we can infer that liftable cannot be true, therefore not liftable is true.
The robot has proved not liftable.
And in this case it appears as a resolution theorem improving is
more complex there's more respondents.
In general it is not.
It just appears here,
because this condition happened to fulfil the form of more respondents directly.
In general, deciding on which sentence to apply the modest ponents on, and
how to combine those groups of inferences don't suddenly become
[INAUDIBLE] harder than deciding how to apply the resolution and improvements.